[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the Trump Gang already
shaming us for all of history by
rounding up good honest law-abiding
Americans without criminal records and
with families who they have started and
raised here and forcibly sending them
back to countries they barely know or do
not know it all may shorten to round up
judges and forcibly send them to the
immigration detention camps at which our
neighbors are being scapegoated and
uprooted from our country so Trump can
fulfill his credo of hate sadism and
barbarism literally forcing judges out
of their homes so they can throw
Americans out of their homes for the
sake of Trump's pointless racist
brutality this is being done in our name
and shame on us the day this was
reported by the Reuters news agency it
largely slipped under the radar a letter
from the Department of Justice asking
for 50 immigration judges to volunteer
to go the word used was deploy to New
York LA Miami New Orleans San Francisco
Baltimore Bloomington Minnesota El Paso
and Harlem in Texas Omaha Phoenix and
Imperial California and perhaps
elsewhere so as to dispense with due
process as quickly as possible start
deporting scapegoats at 6 a.m.
continue deporting scapegoats until 10
p.m. on split shifts for a month or two
at a time and not enough volunteer
judges to quote Reuters if the
department cannot find enough volunteers
the Department would assign judges to
detention centers the sources said what
are we doing what are we doing
you heard the horror stories already
mothers mothers-in-law of military
veterans grandmothers parents
natives of Puerto Rico and their captors
are too stupid to realize Puerto Rico is
in the United States crime victims
people outside homeless shelters
Roberto Barris time described by its
mayor as one of the model citizens of
South Bend Indiana restaurant owner
they're a criminal because at Niagara
Falls one time he reportedly
accidentally walked over into Canadian
territory and husband of a trump voter
Trump fooled her he did say the good
people
would not be deported the good people
would be checked she said madam he lied
to you your husband was deported because
he was easy to find what are we doing
what are we doing to Catalina Guerrero
we've got a 60-day extension before what
is still a scheduled deportation next
month he has reportedly been here more
than 25 years he has two jobs he owns
his own home in New Jersey he pays taxes
has four children four grandchildren as
type 2 diabetes' recently had a stroke
as heart problems uses a cane and has no
criminal record in fact he has been the
victim of a crime in our country a home
invasion
why is trumps ice trying to deport him
he filed for asylum bad legal advice he
says and if you file for asylum and you
don't get it you have to leave he filed
for asylum in 1992 and the ruling
against him came 17 years later on May
22nd we may throw him out because
because he's replicating what my
great-great grandfather did making his
way here because in 1992 as in 1854 we
were the light of the world because both
cavallino Guerrero and Frederick
Olbermann wanted freedom and better
lives maybe not in time for themselves
but in time for their children Cavallino
Guerrero and Frederick Olbermann and how
many of your ancestors and how many of
the ancestors of the unthinking
humanoids who are cheering the Trump
raids and how many of the ancestors of
Trump and we're now relocating judges to
the concentration camps with
instructions to speed it up what are we
doing what are we doing exactly what we
are doing has been expressed poignant
Lee a thousand times through history but
never more so than by a 36 year old man
who faced expulsion from the country he
had called home for his half his life
but whose government now insisted he was
illegal he was not a professional writer
and the plea he made to the prints of
his home region was not written in
English a historian found at last autumn
111 years after it was written the
translation is by Austin Hinckley of
Harper's Magazine and I have made minor
edits to the text for simplicity and
clarity
and to remove the fluffy flattery
towards that royal prince
it is painful but in its own way it is
also beautiful and it should be heard by
everyone in this country as long as this
purge goes on in our name to quote it
my parents were honest plain pious
vineyard workers they strictly held me -
everything good - diligence and piety -
regular attendance in school and church
- absolute obedience toward the high
authority after my confirmation in 1882
I apprenticed to become a barber I
emigrated in 1885 in my 16th year in
America I carried on my business with
diligence discretion and prudence God's
blessing was with me and I became rich I
obtained American citizenship in 1892 in
1902 I met my current wife sadly she
could not tolerate the climate in New
York and I went with my dear family back
home the town was glad to have received
a capable and productive citizen
my old mother was happy to see her son
her dear daughter-in-law and her
granddaughter around her she knows now
that I will take care of her in her old
age but we were confronted all at once
as if my a lightning strike from fair
skies with the news that the ministry
had decided that we must leave our
residence we were paralyzed with fright
our happy family to life was tarnished
my wife has become overcome by anxiety
and my lovely child has become sick why
should we be deported this is very very
hard for a family what war our fellow
citizens think of honest subjects are
faced with such a decree not to mention
the great material losses it would incur
I would like to become a citizen again
in this urgent situation I have no other
recourse than the most humble request
that the highest of all will himself in
mercy deign to allow the applicant to
stay this is signed your most humble and
obedient Fredrick Trump Trump's
grandfather he was in his native Bavaria
deemed illegal and he was rounded up and
deport
and sent back to New York with his
pregnant wife Elizabeth were literally
within months she gave birth to Donald
Trump's father Fred from the grave
Fredrick Elizabeth and Fred Trump and
Frederick Olbermann and millions of
deportees and X aisles and refugees and
millions more who had nowhere to turn
but here are asking us what are we doing
and they are asking Donald Trump what
are you doing
resist